It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. wants to be liked and respected. Whether you're meeting a new colleague, trying to impress your boss, setting up your profile on a dating app, or even just chatting with a neighbor, some part of your brain is probably thinking about how your words and actions are coming across. Sometimes our intuitions are correct, but sometimes they're not. Today we're going to talk to a researcher who studies impression mismanagement, the mistakes we make when we're trying to make other people like us. So why do people so often misjudge what will make a good impression? What are some of the most common mistakes? If you want people to like and respect you, is it better to boast a
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。每个人都希望被喜欢和尊重。无论你是结识新同事、试图给老板留下好印象、在约会软件上设置个人资料，还是仅仅与邻居聊天，你的大脑可能都在思考你的言行会给对方留下怎样的印象。有时我们的直觉是正确的，但有时却不然。今天，我们将采访一位研究“印象管理失当”的研究人员，探讨我们在试图让别人喜欢我们时所犯的错误。那么，为什么人们经常误判什么才能留下好印象？最常见的错误有哪些？如果你想让别人喜欢并尊重你，是稍微吹嘘一下比较好，还是对自己的成就保持沉默比较好？
little bit or stay quiet about your accomplishments? And what about social media? Are the behaviors that make a good impression online, the same ones that work in real life? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Oval Sezer, an assistant professor at Cornell University's SC Johnson School of Business.
社交媒体又如何呢？在网上留下好印象的行为，和在现实生活中奏效的行为是一样的吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是康奈尔大学 SC 约翰逊商学院的助理教授奥瓦尔·塞泽博士。
Her research focuses on the mistakes we make when we want to impress others and how we can better navigate our social world. Questions she's looked at include how can we signal that we're both competent and likable? How can a person brag wisely? And how can we network less awkwardly? Her work has been published in top psychology and management journals and covered in media outlets, including the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, and the Washington Post.
她的研究重点是我们想要给别人留下好印象时所犯的错误，以及我们如何能更好地驾驭我们的社交世界。她研究的问题包括：我们如何才能既表现出能力又让人喜欢？一个人如何才能聪明地吹嘘？我们如何才能不那么尴尬地进行社交？她的研究成果已发表在顶尖的心理学和管理学期刊上，并被《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》和《华盛顿邮报》等媒体报道。
Dr. Sezer, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much, Kim. It's so great to be here. Thanks so much for having me. Now, you call your work impression mismanagement. Can you start by telling us more about that? What is impression mismanagement? And conversely, what is impression management? This is a great question because any time I get asked, what is impression mismanagement? management, I start by explaining what actually is impression management. So that's a great start. So it's definitely the psychology of how we try to look good in front of others, the ways we try to shape how others perceive us, whether we want to come across as likable, warm, competent, high
塞泽博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢，金。很高兴来到这里。非常感谢邀请我。您将您的工作称为“印象管理失当”。您能先告诉我们更多关于这方面的内容吗？什么是印象管理失当？反过来，什么是印象管理？这是一个很好的问题，因为每当有人问我什么是印象管理失当，我都会先解释什么是印象管理。所以这是一个很好的开始。这绝对是关于我们如何试图在他人面前表现良好、我们试图塑造他人对我们看法的方式的心理学，无论我们是想表现得讨人喜欢、热情、能干、高
status, trustworthy. So we all have these goals when we interact with others, whether it's a job interview, negotiation context, presentation in front of it. of clients or, you know, try to get a second date or curating our perfect LinkedIn posts. You know, all of these instances require some impression management and we are all aware of it. Sometimes it will be more conscious, sometimes it will be less conscious, but we're all aware of it because we have this call. And impression mismanagement is when our intuitions go wrong and sometimes we end up engaging in the wrong strategy and we end up shooting ourselves in the because the strategies that we try undermines us, you know, it actually backfire. So that's the
地位还是值得信赖。所以我们在与他人互动时都有这些目标，无论是求职面试、谈判场合、在客户面前做演示，还是试图获得第二次约会，或者精心策划我们完美的领英帖子。你知道，所有这些情况都需要某种印象管理，我们也都意识到了这一点。有时它会更自觉，有时会不那么自觉，但我们都意识到了这一点，因为我们有这个目标。而印象管理失当是指我们的直觉出了错，有时我们最终采取了错误的策略，结果反而弄巧成拙，因为我们尝试的策略削弱了我们自己，实际上适得其反。所以这就是
mismanagement part. And we all have these intuitions coming from somewhere because no one teaches us how to brag. No one teaches us how to do networking. These are the things we learn as we navigate life. So what are some of the most common mistakes that people make when they're trying to get other people to like or respect them? I have a long list of strategies that I looked at so far, both, I mean, since my dissertation research are now as an assistant professor. So if I go on and on, you can stop me any time. Because I'm very passionate about this and I love talking about this. So it all started with my dissertation work where we try to understand what are some more sophisticated self-promotion strategies that people engage in. Because we all know bragging is not the most desirable thing, right?
管理失当的部分。我们都有这些直觉，它们来自某个地方，因为没有人教我们如何吹嘘。没有人教我们如何进行社交。这些是我们随着生活经历而学到的东西。那么，人们在试图让别人喜欢或尊重他们时，最常犯的错误有哪些？到目前为止，我研究过一长串策略，从我的博士研究到现在担任助理教授。所以如果我一直说下去，你可以随时打断我。因为我对这个非常热衷，而且我喜欢谈论这个。这一切都始于我的博士工作，当时我们试图了解人们参与的一些更复杂的自我推销策略。因为我们都知道吹嘘不是最理想的事情，对吧？
We all know that, even since very young age, we are aware, oh, I don't need to be too arrogant. I shouldn't be too arrogant because we want to be invited to parties and, you know, included in all the friends settings. So we don't want to brag too much. So that intuition is right. It's a universal value, modesty, humility. These are things that we all care about across cultures. But people do this interesting thing called humble bragging. and I would like to welcome everybody to my world of social paranoia because now I'm going to notice my humble brags during this podcast.
我们都知道这一点，即使从很小的时候起，我们就意识到，哦，我不需要太傲慢。我不应该太傲慢，因为我们想被邀请参加聚会，并被包含在所有的朋友聚会中。所以我们不想吹嘘太多。所以这种直觉是正确的。这是一种普遍的价值观，谦虚、谦逊。这些是我们跨文化都关心的东西。但人们会做一种有趣的名为“谦虚式吹嘘”的事情。我想欢迎大家来到我的社交偏执世界，因为现在我会在这个播客中注意到我自己的谦虚式吹嘘。
And maybe our audience will also start catching more humble brags as they listen to because that's exactly what happened to me when I first started investigating this phenomenon. So it's basically bragging masked by complaint or false humility. So if I say something like, oh my goodness, why do people hit on me even when I'm my, you know, when I'm a, you know, when I'm a. in my sweatpants, you know, oh, do Uber driver thought I'm 23, you know, does that make sense? Isn't that? Or I can't believe I got this award, you know, thank you so much. I, you know, I can go on. Maybe, maybe I'll give some meta-humble brags. You know, it's so hard to be invited to podcast all the time, Kim, you know, I just, okay, I'll stop. I'll stop. But you can see how
也许我们的听众在收听时也会开始捕捉到更多的谦虚式吹嘘，因为这正是我刚开始调查这种现象时发生在我身上的事情。所以它基本上是被抱怨或虚假谦虚所掩盖的吹嘘。所以如果我说类似这样的话，“哦，天哪，为什么即使我穿着运动裤，人们也会搭讪我？哦，优步司机以为我才 23 岁。”这有意义吗？这不是吗？或者“我不敢相信我获得了这个奖项，非常感谢。”我可以继续说下去。也许，也许我会给出一些元谦虚式吹嘘。你知道，一直被邀请参加播客太难了，金，你知道，我只是，好吧，我会停下来。我会停下来的。但你可以看到它是如何
it. It's very common. It is absolutely very common. And of course, like some of the examples that I give right now. I mean, seemingly outrageous and funny, I do it on purpose. But even in instances where it's not funny, like when people get the job interview of questions, what's your biggest weakness? A lot of people end up saying, I'm a perfectionist, I work too hard, oh, I'm too nice, I prioritize my friends and family. People list all their great qualities as if they are weaknesses. So it happens all the time. And what we found was that even though people do it because they know bragging is bad and they think this is going to provide that sweet spots best of both worlds. Oh, I'm going to brag, but I'm going to soften it. So I'm going to
它非常普遍。它绝对非常普遍。当然，就像我现在给出的一些例子一样。我的意思是，看似离谱且有趣，我是故意这样做的。但即使在不那么有趣的情况下，比如当人们在求职面试中被问到“你最大的弱点是什么？”时，很多人最终会说，“我是个完美主义者，我工作太努力了，哦，我太好了，我把朋友和家人放在首位。”人们列出他们所有的优点，就好像它们是弱点一样。所以这种情况一直都在发生。我们发现，尽管人们这样做是因为他们知道吹嘘是不好的，并且他们认为这会提供那个两全其美的“甜蜜点”。哦，我要吹嘘，但我会把它软化。所以我会
both conway my great qualities and accomplishments, but I will soften it. I will, you know, frame it as a complaint or a little modest thing. But what ends up happening is that it actually backfires. It's worse than straightforward with bragging. And the reason is because it comes across is very insincere. It's a, you know, being sincere, being authentic is something that we value a lot in others. So when when the person is trying to brag but trying to hide it, it's actually more offensive to the recipient. So we don't, we don't like it.
既传达我的优点和成就，但我会软化它。我会把它包装成一种抱怨或一点点谦虚。但最终发生的是，它实际上适得其反。它比直接吹嘘更糟糕。原因是因为它显得非常不真诚。真诚、真实是我们非常看重他人的品质。所以当一个人试图吹嘘但又试图隐藏它时，这对接收者来说实际上更令人反感。所以我们不喜欢它。
So humble bragging is one of the common mistakes that happen. Anytime I talk about this work, I used to get the question, oh, what if I don't share anything? What if I don't say anything? Now, the first risk about that in the world of, you know, I think we can say that our world is full of self-promotion right now with the existence of social media. You know, just one quick look at LinkedIn or Instagram is enough. You know, you would never feel lack of self-promotion around you.
所以谦虚式吹嘘是常见的错误之一。每当我谈论这项工作时，我过去常被问到，“如果我不分享任何东西怎么办？如果我不说任何话怎么办？”现在，在社交媒体存在的世界里，关于这一点，第一个风险是，我想我们可以说我们的世界现在充满了自我推销。只要看一眼领英或 Instagram 就足够了。你永远不会觉得周围缺乏自我推销。
So if we don't share anything, there is the risk of missing out because now we live in a world where we need to emphasize our expertise. I don't mean to say we should brag all the time. But I just want to say, not saying anything and staying quiet has its own risks. But if you have something good to share, and if you don't share it, and we had this paper, we called it hiding success, especially the people around you who are close to you. Like maybe your close work friends, close friends and some family members, they do get offended a little bit this time because they think, oh, you don't think I'm going to be happy for you? Like, that's offensive. Or do you think I'm going to be, you know, jealous of you?
所以如果我们不分享任何东西，就有错失良机的风险，因为现在我们生活在一个需要强调我们专业知识的世界里。我并不是说我们应该一直吹嘘。但我只是想说，什么都不说并保持沉默有其自身的风险。但如果你有什么好的东西可以分享，而你不分享，我们有一篇论文，我们称之为“隐藏成功”，特别是对你身边亲近的人。比如你亲近的工作朋友、好朋友和一些家庭成员，他们这次确实会感到有点被冒犯，因为他们会想，“哦，你觉得我不会为你感到高兴吗？那太冒犯了。”或者“你觉得我会嫉妒你吗？”
So there is that sometimes it backfires, even though we have the good intentions of not, you know, not looking arrogant and not offending everybody. Sometimes it ends up being offensive because people think, oh, you are trying to regulate my emotional reaction to your success. I would just be happy for you. So that backfires as well. And that's a very common thing. And the reason why I say these are common strategies because we did run lots of, I mean, first of all, they're common on social media and we did analyze that data. But we also survey people or run diary studies with people where people report surveys every day at a certain time for us.
所以有时它会适得其反，尽管我们有不显得傲慢和不冒犯所有人的良好意图。有时它最终会令人反感，因为人们会想，“哦，你是在试图调节我对你成功的心理反应。我本来会为你感到高兴的。”所以这也适得其反。这是一个非常普遍的事情。我之所以说这些是常见的策略，是因为我们确实进行了大量的研究，首先，它们在社交媒体上很常见，我们分析了这些数据。但我们也对人们进行了调查，或者与人们进行了日记研究，人们每天在特定时间为我们报告调查结果。
Or we ask people, you know, have you ever hidden success from somebody else? And the answers were very interesting because from, like, it starts very young. Like, oh, I used to get better grades than my, you know, classmate in primary school. And I didn't say that. Or I never shared the name of my high school. high status school name in my family, like things like that. People try to navigate that all the time. So that's why I say these intuitions are very common, but they end up not working. And other things as well. Like I study name dropping, you know, where you casually drop a name into conversation. Now I'm sure I'm going to do that during this interview.
或者我们问人们，“你有没有向别人隐藏过成功？”答案非常有趣，因为从很小的时候就开始了。比如，“我过去在小学时成绩比我的同学好。但我没说。或者我从未在家人面前分享过我名校的名字。”人们一直在试图驾驭这些。这就是为什么我说这些直觉非常普遍，但它们最终并不奏效。还有其他事情。比如我研究“名牌效应”，即你在谈话中随意提到某个大人物的名字。现在我敢肯定我会在这次采访中这样做。
Or I also study compliments or thank yous or apologies and there are always or advice giving advice taking. And there are things that we do wrong in this domain as well. For instance, people sometimes make their compliments backhanded. You know, if someone tells me, oh, your English is pretty good for an international. I would be like, what do you mean? My English is amazing. Or if someone tells me you're funny for a woman because, you know, I try to do stand-up comedy. Yeah, I try to do stand-up comedy as a hobby.
或者我也研究赞美、感谢或道歉，总是有建议给予或建议采纳。在这个领域我们也会做错事情。例如，人们有时会进行“反向赞美”。你知道，如果有人告诉我，“哦，对于一个国际人士来说，你的英语相当不错。”我会想，“你什么意思？我的英语很棒。”或者如果有人告诉我，“作为一个女性，你很有趣，因为，你知道，我尝试做单口喜剧。”是的，我尝试把单口喜剧作为一种爱好。
So I would be like, no way, that's not necessarily a compliment. So things like that. There are lots of different versions we can talk about. How cognizant do you think people are of doing these things? When people are interacting with others, we are very aware. Look, when someone else does it. And we don't even care whether it's true or not. Someone can really maybe complaining about having lots of job offers and stuff like that in a genuine way.
所以我会想，“没门，那不一定是一种赞美。”所以类似的事情。我们可以谈论很多不同的版本。你认为人们对做这些事情有多清醒？当人们与他人互动时，我们非常清楚。看，当别人这样做时。我们甚至不在乎它是否属实。有人可能真的在以一种真诚的方式抱怨有很多工作机会之类的。
Maybe they really mean it. But for us, we would be like, oh, that's like a humble brag. You know, that's like kind of a weird thing to say. But in our experiments, anytime we put people positions and we give them impression management goals, like imagine I take you to my lab and I say, you're going to talk with another person for five minutes, either through chat or face-to-face. And let's say I tell you, your goal is to impress the other person. You know, try to impress them.
也许他们真的是这个意思。但对我们来说，我们会想，“哦，那就像是一种谦虚式吹嘘。”你知道，那是一种奇怪的说法。但在我们的实验中，每当我们把人们放在特定的位置并给他们印象管理目标时，比如想象我把你带到我的实验室，我说，“你将与另一个人交谈五分钟，通过聊天或面对面。假设我告诉你，你的目标是给对方留下深刻印象。你知道，试着给他们留下深刻印象。”
And I'm going to ask them at the end of your interaction how impressive you were. And based on how they rate you, I'm going to give you bonus money. So I incentivize you to, for this goal, right? And, you know, when people are in this position, they do, they do become less cognizant of these behavior. Then we do, you know, brag. We do humble brag. We do these other behaviors. So I think when we are in the position of presenting ourselves, we somehow forget.
“我会在你们互动结束时问他们你有多令人印象深刻。根据他们对你的评价，我会给你奖金。”所以为了这个目标，我激励了你，对吧？而且，你知道，当人们处于这个位置时，他们确实对这些行为变得不那么清醒了。然后我们确实吹嘘了。我们确实进行了谦虚式吹嘘。我们确实进行了这些其他行为。所以我认为当我们处于展示自己的位置时，我们不知何故忘记了。
I think another reason, by the way, that these mistakes still exist and it's so hard to learn over time. we never get in-time feedback. You know, no one, Roman rolls their eyes in front of us or, you know, there's no, right. Yeah, or there's no dislike button on LinkedIn. You know, it's all, it's designed that way. Exactly. No one tells it to our face that it was kind of a weird thing to say.
我认为顺便说一句，这些错误仍然存在且随着时间推移很难学习的另一个原因是，我们从未得到及时的反馈。你知道，没有人会在我们面前翻白眼，或者，你知道，没有，对。是的，或者领英上没有“不喜欢”按钮。你知道，它就是这样设计的。完全正确。没有人当面告诉我们那是一种奇怪的说法。
So you end up navigating always with your intuition. Why do people make these mistakes? I mean, you mentioned that we don't really learn how to make a first impression. I mean, is that something that should be taught somewhere in life? I think so. I think, you know, I do teach impression management classes in my leadership class, you know, when I teach both MBAs and undergrads. So I think there are definitely things we can learn.
所以你最终总是凭直觉行事。为什么人们会犯这些错误？我的意思是，你提到我们并没有真正学会如何留下第一印象。我的意思是，那是生活中应该在某处教授的东西吗？我想是的。我认为，你知道，我在我的领导力课程中确实教授印象管理课程，你知道，当我教 MBA 和本科生时。所以我认为肯定有一些东西我们可以学习。
But your question about why do we even make these mistakes even a bigger one? So some of it comes from we never learn because we don't get the feedback. I think some of it comes from the problem of having multiple audience in the room. And with the way that internet works or social media works, it became even stronger. What I mean by multiple audiences is that having our family members or our parents and our boss and our team members in the same network makes it very hard. So here's what I mean by that. If I say, so, you know, for us, for academics, a publishing paper is one measure of success, right?
但关于为什么我们甚至会犯这些错误的问题，甚至是一个更大的问题。所以其中一些来自于我们从未学习，因为我们没有得到反馈。我认为其中一些来自于房间里有多个受众的问题。随着互联网或社交媒体的工作方式，它变得更加强烈。我所说的多个受众是指让我们的家庭成员或我们的父母、我们的老板和我们的团队成员在同一个网络中，这使得它变得非常困难。所以我指的是：如果我说，你知道，对我们学者来说，发表论文是衡量成功的一种标准，对吧？
It's a great thing for us. We get very happy. Even if only five people read our paper, we're still very, very happy because it's a contribution and we worked hard on it. And if I share it, let's say, with my mom, there's no way she can, she will code it as bragging. She'll be like, oh, that's wonderful. Right.
这对我们来说是一件伟大的事情。我们感到非常高兴。即使只有五个人读了我们的论文，我们仍然非常、非常高兴，因为这是一种贡献，而且我们为此努力工作。如果我分享它，比如说，和我妈妈分享，她不可能把它解读为吹嘘。她会说，“哦，那太棒了。”对。
Or same thing, if we share things like this, like our, promotion, our award with someone like a boss, they'll be proud of us. But if we shared with a peer who was aiming for maybe the same award, same promotion, then things change, right, because we have the whole social comparison dynamic there. But right now, because everyone is available all the time in the same platform, we have this multiple audience issue. Everyone is in the same room, and how do I create that profile? Now, that's why sometimes you would see, you know, some people just do professional social media and personal social media separately. They try to create separate pages for that, which I totally understand why.
或者同样的事情，如果我们分享这样的事情，比如我们的晋升、我们的奖项，和像老板这样的人分享，他们会为我们感到骄傲。但如果我们和可能也在争取同样奖项、同样晋升的同事分享，那么情况就变了，对吧，因为我们那里有整个社会比较的动态。但现在，因为每个人都在同一个平台上随时可用，我们有这个多个受众的问题。每个人都在同一个房间里，我该如何创建那个个人资料？现在，这就是为什么有时你会看到，你知道，有些人只是把专业社交媒体和个人社交媒体分开。他们试图为此创建单独的页面，我完全理解为什么。
Another reason why we make these mistakes, sometimes we try to regulate our own emotions. It feels good to brag that there is research by some wonderful colleagues. It feels good. Like we feel good when we feel positive when we brag. Even though there is that discomfort when we think of other people's interactions, There is definitely this pride is a very interesting self-conscious emotion. And, you know, we like that. And sometimes we engage in these mistakes because we are trying to feel good about ourselves.
我们犯这些错误的另一个原因是，有时我们试图调节我们自己的情绪。吹嘘感觉很好，有一些出色的同事的研究表明。它感觉很好。就像当我们吹嘘时，我们感到积极，我们感觉很好。尽管当我们想到别人的互动时会有那种不适感，但这种自豪感绝对是一种非常有趣的自我意识情绪。而且，你知道，我们喜欢那样。有时我们参与这些错误是因为我们试图对自己感觉良好。
And sometimes we just, it's a perspective taking mistakes. Sometimes we just don't understand how it's going to come across to the other side. So there are these multiple different processes. Sometimes it's the emotional reason. Sometimes, you know, other people are in the room and there are just so many different goals with any of these relationships. The way that I interact with my best friend is not the same as I interact with my boss. But if they're all in my LinkedIn post, there's no, I need to choose one style. There's, you know, so things like that make the mistakes are even more inevitable in that way.
有时我们只是，这是一个换位思考的错误。有时我们只是不明白它在对方看来会是什么样子。所以有这些多种不同的过程。有时是情感原因，有时，你知道，其他人也在房间里，在任何这些关系中都有太多的不同目标。我与我最好的朋友互动的方式与我与老板互动的方式不同。但如果他们都在我的领英帖子中，没有，我需要选择一种风格。有，你知道，所以类似的事情使得错误在那种方式下更加不可避免。
We were talking a moment ago about the workplace and, you know, that cliche question about what's your greatest weakness. Another thing that comes up in some workplaces is the 360 degree evaluation. since you do this kind of work, I mean, how useful is that to people? Do they really learn anything from a 360 when all is said and done? I think 360 evaluations, I think, may work if people really believe that they're really anonymous and no one is, you know, getting the, so the status differences definitely do play a role because no one wants to be giving a negative feedback to their superior or their boss when their name or identity can be found out, for sure. sure. So people definitely have that concern. I think the way that people respond to 360 feedback makes it even likely to work or not. And I'm going to give you the example of what we studied. This is also kind of related to impression management. But it's also related to feedback taking
我们刚才在谈论工作场所，你知道，关于“你最大的弱点是什么”的那个陈词滥调的问题。在一些工作场所出现的另一件事是 360 度评估。既然你做这种工作，我的意思是，这对人们有多大用处？归根结底，他们真的从 360 度评估中学到了什么吗？我认为 360 度评估，我认为，如果人们真的相信它们是真正匿名的，而且没有人，你知道，得到，所以地位差异肯定起作用，因为当他们的名字或身份可能被发现时，没有人愿意给他们的上级或老板负面反馈，这是肯定的。所以人们肯定有这种担忧。我认为人们对 360 度反馈的反应方式使得它是否有效变得更加可能。我将给你一个我们研究过的例子。这也与印象管理有点相关。但它也与反馈采纳
and authenticity. So we looked at how leaders react to 360 feedback because they get feedback from people who work as your direct reports. And when people, especially when leaders get negative feedback, they have this bias. They want to address it very quickly. They say, here it is, I listen to you, I look at your feedback, and I hear you, and I incorporate this change immediately. But what we found is that when that change happens very quickly and very immediately, other people don't find it authentic. They think, oh, you only change because I gave you that feedback, but it's not internalized. You know, you didn't think about it. You didn't reflect on it. You didn't internalize it. But when it's done in a way that's a bit gradual and
和真实性有关。所以我们研究了领导者如何对 360 度反馈做出反应，因为他们从作为你的直接下属工作的人那里得到反馈。当人们，特别是当领导者得到负面反馈时，他们有这种偏见。他们想非常快地解决它。他们说，“在这里，我听到了，我看了你的反馈，我听到了你的声音，我立即纳入了这个改变。”但我们发现，当这种改变发生得非常快且非常立即时，其他人并不觉得它真实。他们会想，“哦，你只是因为我给了你那个反馈才改变，但它没有被内化。”你知道，你没有思考它。你没有反思它。你没有内化它。但当它以一种有点渐进的方式完成时，并且
over time, then people really think you really pay attention. Right. So that's one, it's not necessarily an impression management mistake, but it's like a feedback mistake where it hurts your, how authentic you come across. So it ends up being an impression management mistake, right? So, you know, when we get feedback, we shouldn't be too quick to address it. We should still tell people we hear them and we're working on it. But it should, it should, it should be. It should, should be a long-term gradual change rather than very immediate, very quick, loud change. So sometimes this gradual change is more effective in terms of coming across as an authentic leader. So based on that, I can tell you that, you know, 360 feedback may work, but it depends how we react to it.
随着时间的推移，人们真的认为你真的注意到了。对。所以这是一个，它不一定是印象管理错误，但它就像一个反馈错误，它伤害了你，你表现得有多真实。所以它最终成为了一个印象管理错误，对吧？所以，你知道，当我们得到反馈时，我们不应该太快去解决它。我们仍然应该告诉人们我们听到了他们的声音，我们正在努力解决它。但它应该，它应该，它应该。它应该是一个长期的渐进式改变，而不是非常立即、非常快速、大声的改变。所以有时这种渐进式改变在表现为真实领导者方面更有效。基于此，我可以告诉你，你知道，360 度反馈可能有效，但这取决于我们如何对它做出反应。
I don't know if I answer your question or this was very specific about the paper too, but as you know, I look for opportunities to brag. so thank you for letting us know that this paper is coming out. Okay. Exactly. Thank you for giving me the opportunity. I thought it's a bit relevant with the authenticity angle too, so I wanted to share that. I just want the listeners to know that we didn't set this up so that you could brag. Absolutely. Yeah, this was all authentic. I didn't know about your paper. Yeah. Yeah, this was totally authentic. Let me ask you going down on another lane here, have you found? Have you found out?
我不知道我是否回答了你的问题，或者这是否也非常具体关于那篇论文，但正如你所知，我寻找吹嘘的机会。所以谢谢你让我们知道这篇论文即将发表。好的。完全正确。谢谢你给我这个机会。我想它与真实性角度也有点相关，所以我想分享一下。我只是想让听众知道我们没有设置这个，以便你可以吹嘘。绝对。是的，这完全是真实的。我不知道你的论文。是的。是的，这完全是真实的。让我问你，沿着另一条路走，你有没有发现？你有没有发现？
any gender or cultural differences in how people handle impression management or mismanagement or how they respond to people who might be using some of the strategies to make a better impression? The answer is absolutely yes because both gender and cultural differences determine our norms and how we are perceived or whether we engage in this behavior or not really depends on the social norms around us. I mean, even when we think of social media, You know, I'm always curious, how did it become what it is today? You know, I recently went back to my Twitter feed that I wanted to find out what's the very first tweet I shared with the world. And it was like, I like to cook.
任何性别或文化差异在人们如何处理印象管理或管理失当，或者他们如何回应那些可能正在使用一些策略来留下更好印象的人？答案是绝对肯定的，因为性别和文化差异都决定了我们的规范，以及我们如何被感知，或者我们是否参与这种行为，真的取决于我们周围的社会规范。我的意思是，即使当我们想到社交媒体时，你知道，我总是很好奇，它是如何变成今天这个样子的？你知道，我最近回到了我的推特动态，我想找出我与世界分享的第一条推文是什么。它是，“我喜欢做饭。”
That was my first tweet, which probably doesn't make sense in today's world. You know, why did I share that? But you didn't say, I'm a good cook. No, I just said I. because probably at the time there wasn't that much of bragging norm or when Facebook first got into our lives or LinkedIn, it was a different thing and now it's a much different thing.
那是我的第一条推文，在当今世界可能没有意义。你知道，我为什么要分享那个？但你没有说，“我是一个好厨师。”不，我只是说我。因为可能在当时没有那么多的吹嘘规范，或者当 Facebook 第一次进入我们的生活或领英时，它是另一回事，而现在它是非常不同的一回事。
So norms definitely determine how we behave in this platforms and in real life as well and gender and cultural differences are absolutely key ingredients for social norms. So when it comes to gender, there's definitely the role theory, as researchers would call it, would explain. There's expected roles from,
所以规范绝对决定了我们在这些平台上的行为方式，在现实生活中也是如此，性别和文化差异绝对是社会规范的关键成分。所以当谈到性别时，绝对有角色理论，正如研究人员所称的那样，会解释。有来自的预期角色
men and women and women know that modesty is a more communal, more warmth-related norm, which is associated more with female characteristics. So women know that it's going to hurt them more and it actually does hurt them more a little bit. Like bragging is not the same for a man versus for a woman. So women receive a little bit more backlash. And because of that, I think women, the direct self-promotion of first white women are little less. There's more indirect self-promotion efforts engaged by women. And it's a very tricky balance, of course, you know, because what I find in my dissertation work was also that even the
男人和女人，女人知道谦虚是一种更公共、更与温暖相关的规范，这与女性特征联系得更多。所以女人知道这会伤害她们更多，而且它实际上确实伤害了她们更多一点。比如吹嘘对于男人和女人来说是不一样的。所以女性受到的反弹稍微多一点。正因为如此，我认为女性，白人女性的直接自我推销稍微少一点。女性参与了更多的间接自我推销努力。当然，这是一个非常棘手的平衡，你知道，因为我在我的博士工作中发现的也是，甚至
domain of the bragging, the topic of bragging matters too. You know, when we brag about leadership versus when we brag about cooking or things like that also changes the norms around this. So women receive more backlash when there's direct self-promotion. And because they are aware of it and it's because it's an expected behavior. Modesty is expected more by women. You know, they refrain a little bit more from self-promotion. And cultural differences definitely determine how these efforts are perceived, especially when it comes to collectivistic cultures versus individualistic cultures. Like some cultures are more collectivistic. Some cultures are more individualistic. We haven't published this, but I did get a chance when we
吹嘘的领域，吹嘘的主题也很重要。你知道，当我们吹嘘领导力与当我们吹嘘烹饪或类似的事情时，也会改变围绕这个的规范。所以当有直接自我推销时，女性受到的反弹更多。而且因为她们意识到了这一点，而且因为这是一种预期的行为。谦虚更受女性预期。你知道，她们在自我推销方面稍微克制了一点。而且文化差异绝对决定了这些努力是如何被感知的，特别是在集体主义文化与个人主义文化方面。比如一些文化更集体主义。一些文化更个人主义。我们还没有发表这个，但我确实有机会，当我们
I did run only one study, so I'm going to give this with that. But even in that one experiment when we ran the experiment with US participants and also Japan, partisanship from Japan, where Japanese culture is much more collectivistic than US culture, humble bragging there wasn't that bad because humility is much more of a value there, right? People definitely deflect bragging in a genuine way because no one wants to say, I, me, I did this, I'm the best, like, that's very forbidden in those cultures. So we did find that difference in that one study I could run. So there's definitely cross-cultural differences there.
我确实只做了一项研究，所以我将带着这个给出。但即使在那一个实验中，当我们用美国参与者和日本参与者进行实验时，来自日本的党派，日本文化比美国文化更集体主义，那里的谦虚式吹嘘并没有那么糟糕，因为谦逊在那里更是一种价值，对吧？人们绝对以一种真诚的方式抵消吹嘘，因为没有人想说，“我，我，我做了这个，我是最好的，”比如，这在那些文化中是非常禁止的。所以我们确实在那一项我可以做的研究中发现了那种差异。所以那里绝对有跨文化差异。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Sezer about how to balance being liked and being respected by others. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.
我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与塞泽博士谈谈如何平衡被喜欢和被他人尊重。你的夏天现在开始，在家得宝享受阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。是时候用 Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。并用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待整个季节，仅需 499 美元。
This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝获得保证的低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？
Enough. Enough to save. get lost? Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. There's a term that has come into common usage in the U.S. in, I don't know, the last few years, mansplaining. And I'm just wondering. if that is a reflection of the fact that men do tend to sort of take over and tell you what they know. And is that a form of impression mismanagement?
足够了。足够省钱。迷路了？或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省 20%，获得你预期的住宿。当你想要节省，而不是惊喜时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。在美国，有一个术语在过去几年里变得很常用，“男式说教”（mansplaining）。我只是想知道。如果这反映了男人确实倾向于接管并告诉你他们知道什么的事实。这是一种印象管理失当的形式吗？
Yeah, that's a great question too. You know, we did have some studies around this phenomenon, too know, because especially this term mansplaining was very, it's still common, but it had its very popular day a few years ago maybe. It is true that a lot of people do say they experience mansplaining, especially in the workplace. What we find is that it's usually status explaining, though. You know, like when there's high status positions are occupied by mostly men at this point in our lives,
是的，这也是一个很好的问题。你知道，我们确实围绕这种现象进行了一些研究，你知道，因为特别是“男式说教”这个术语非常，它仍然很常见，但它几年前可能有一个非常流行的日子。确实很多人确实说他们经历了男式说教，特别是在工作场所。我们发现，它通常是地位解释，虽然。你知道，比如当高地位职位在此时此刻我们的生活中主要由男性占据时，
everywhere in the world, and high status gives that drive to, let me explain things to you. And sometimes again, but I mean, this was just survey-based data, so people's self-report experiences, but people do find that not all mansplaining are equal, meaning that sometimes it backfires and it's an example of impression mismanagement because it's a bit condescending. You know, some people, you know, like, if someone explains to me how to, I don't know,
在世界各地，高地位给了那种驱动力，“让我为你解释事情。”有时再次，但我的意思是，这只是基于调查的数据，所以人们的自我报告经历，但人们确实发现并非所有的男式说教都是平等的，这意味着有时它会适得其反，它是印象管理失当的一个例子，因为它有点屈尊俯就。你知道，有些人，你知道，比如，如果有人向我解释如何，我不知道，
how to watch sports just because, you know, I'm women, things like that would be an example of that, for instance. So, so yeah, sometimes advice giving that if it happens in the form of mansplaining or status explaining, so sometimes it can be also woman's explaining, I guess, My status agent is a woman.
如何观看体育比赛，仅仅因为，你知道，我是女性，类似的事情将是其中的一个例子，例如。所以，所以是的，有时建议给予，如果它以男式说教或地位解释的形式发生，所以有时它也可以是女式说教，我想，我的地位代理人是一个女人。
It does backfire because even it does backfire because of two things. Sometimes it can be based on gender stereotypes, which are, of course, offensive. You know, when I said the sports example. I know I'm a huge soccer fan. I know soccer rules more than anybody else. And that's definitely offensive. But sometimes it just happens because of status differences and people just don't know where to put you, especially if you're on the younger end.
它确实适得其反，因为即使它确实适得其反，因为两件事。有时它可能基于性别刻板印象，这当然是令人反感的。你知道，当我提到体育例子时。我知道我是一个巨大的足球迷。我比任何人都更了解足球规则。这绝对是令人反感的。但有时它只是因为地位差异而发生，人们只是不知道把你放在哪里，特别是如果你在年轻的一端。
That's why sometimes even men receive mansplaining too, because if they are young and if they seem like they don't know what they're doing, even though they would know, but just based on the perceived level of their status and their age, and then you get this unsolicited advice that may end up being condescending, regardless of what the intention of the explainer was. So it can definitely be a form of impression mismanagement there. Can people use techniques to sort of attenuate the bad reaction that they might be getting? So, for example, when you kind of say to people, hey, I don't, how much do you know about sports?
这就是为什么有时甚至男人也会受到男式说教，因为如果他们年轻，如果他们看起来好像不知道自己在做什么，即使他们会知道，但仅仅基于他们地位和年龄的感知水平，然后你得到这种未经请求的建议，最终可能会变得屈尊俯就，无论解释者的意图是什么。所以它绝对可以是那里的一种印象管理失当的形式。人们可以使用技术来减轻他们可能得到的坏反应吗？所以，例如，当你对人们说，“嘿，我不，你对体育了解多少？”
I mean, because I know a lot about this particular sport. And so sort of opening the door to letting the other person know or say to you, yeah, I'm very familiar, say, with soccer, then you can like approach each other more on an equal level. Does that help? Absolutely. In fact, you know, I'm a big fan of these pre-exploitations. That's why probably in any social interaction that I'm in, I give this long introductions to any topic because probably I'm very. aware of this. As I said, I've been a social paranoia as someone who studies these things. I think it's always a good idea to give some more information about context or yourself or ask
我的意思是，因为我非常了解这项特定的运动。所以打开大门让对方知道或对你说，“是的，我非常熟悉，比如说，足球，”然后你可以像在更平等的水平上接近彼此。那有帮助吗？绝对。事实上，你知道，我是这些预先解释的忠实粉丝。这就是为什么可能在我参与的任何社交互动中，我对任何主题都给出这些冗长的介绍，因为可能我非常。意识到这一点。正如我所说，我是一个社会偏执狂，作为一个研究这些东西的人。我认为提供更多关于背景或你自己的信息或询问总是好主意
the other person. We also know that asking questions is a great strategy because people love talking about themselves. So, you know, if you ask questions, people always love it. It also signals that you're curious about them. If you share and you ask a question, you're curious about I mean, curiosity is one of the things that we can all aim to induce in others. In fact, for bragging, you know, the best strategy is to find a wink person for our brags. So if someone brags on behalf of us, when we are not present, that's the best thing that can happen. So let's make a pact, Kim, from now on, I'm going to brag about you. Please brag about me, and we have this our friendly, friendly brag loop going on.
对方。我们也知道提问是一个很好的策略，因为人们喜欢谈论自己。所以，你知道，如果你提问，人们总是喜欢它。它也表明你对他们感到好奇。如果你分享并提问，你对，我的意思是，好奇心是我们都可以旨在诱导他人的事情之一。事实上，对于吹嘘，你知道，最好的策略是为我们的吹嘘找到一个“眨眼的人”。所以如果有人代表我们吹嘘，当我们不在场时，那是可能发生的最好的事情。所以让我们达成一个协议，金，从现在开始，我要吹嘘你。请吹嘘我，我们有这个我们友好的、友好的吹嘘循环。
All right, that's a deal. Yeah, and I think the reason why it works very well, Because number one, you're not there. So there's no ulterior motive. No one questions the legitimacy of this brag. Number two, you are curious about the person. Like, if you hear about someone from another person, you're like, oh, let me check.
好的，成交。是的，而且我认为它运作得很好的原因，因为第一，你不在那里。所以没有不可告人的动机。没有人质疑这种吹嘘的合法性。第二，你对这个人感到好奇。比如，如果你从另一个人那里听说某人，你会想，“哦，让我看看。”
Do they have, you know, can I Google them? Are they on Instagram? You know, like, what's the work that they do? Do they have, like, websites where I can learn about their work? So curiosity is a very important piece. So asking questions or finding someone else to brag for us. are great strategies. And going back to your question,
他们有，你知道，我可以谷歌他们吗？他们在 Instagram 上吗？你知道，他们做的工作是什么？他们有，比如，我可以了解他们工作的网站吗？所以好奇心是一个非常重要的部分。所以提问或找别人为我们吹嘘。是很好的策略。回到你的问题，
that's why, you know, if you're in a situation where our level is not necessarily well known by the other person or we don't know their knowledge level, if we can ask questions, we can share where we're coming from. And that would stop all of the misunderstanding
这就是为什么，你知道，如果你处于一种我们的水平不一定被对方很好地了解的情况，或者我们不知道他们的知识水平，如果我们能提问，我们可以分享我们来自哪里。那将停止所有的误解
around advice giving or advice taking. And I'll say a few things about in general how it's a great idea. I said both asking questions, but also sharing our journey too, which is another research that we did. So I'm all a fan of these explanations and these extra conversations so that there's no mismanagement or misunderstanding. Another thing that you've written about is how tough it is to balance trying to be liked and trying to be respected.
围绕建议给予或建议采纳。而且我会说一些关于它总体上是一个好主意的事情。我说既提问，也分享我们的旅程，这是我们做的另一项研究。所以我都是这些解释和这些额外对话的粉丝，这样就不会有管理失当或误解。你写过的另一件事是平衡试图被喜欢和试图被尊重是多么困难。
So can you talk about that? I mean, how do you pull off that balancing act? It's probably the question that all impression management researchers or social cognition, social perception researchers around the world think about every day all the time, because it's called the self-promotion paradox. So what we know from social perception literature is that when we meet with someone, when we evaluate others, there are these two universal dimensions that we care about, warmth and competence. So when I meet with someone, I care about whether they are friendly, warm, nice, do I want to hang out with them? And I also care about are they smart, capable, competence. Do I want to work with them?
所以你能谈谈那个吗？我的意思是，你如何完成那个平衡行为？这可能是全世界所有印象管理研究人员或社会认知、社会感知研究人员每天都在思考的问题，因为它被称为“自我推销悖论”。所以我们从社会感知文献中知道的是，当我们与某人见面时，当我们评估他人时，有两个我们关心的普遍维度，温暖和能力。所以当我与某人见面时，我关心他们是否友好、温暖、好，我想和他们一起出去玩吗？我也关心他们是否聪明、有能力、能力。我想和他们一起工作吗？
or, you know, can I interact with them in that context? Now, the tricky thing, the self-promotion paradox, comes from the strategies that take us to high warmth or high likability, don't make us look highly competent. So I'm going to give examples. You know, if we smile all the time, if we agree all the time, if you're very conforming, if you're like getting gifts to other people, getting, you know, giving compliments to other people, these things would make us be liked. everyone would like us, but no one would necessarily think, oh my God, look at that person.
或者，你知道，我能在那种情境下与他们互动吗？现在，棘手的问题在于“自我推销悖论”，它源于那些能让我们显得亲切或讨人喜欢的策略，往往无法让我们看起来能力出众。所以我来举几个例子。你知道，如果我们一直微笑，一直表示赞同，表现得非常顺从，或者给别人送礼物、夸奖别人，这些行为确实会让我们受欢迎。每个人都会喜欢我们，但未必会觉得“天哪，看看那个人”。
They got a PhD. They're a very interesting person who did all of these accomplishments in their career life. And vice versa, you know, if I'm competent, if I co-mey my expertise, if I just talk about my accomplishments, then people wouldn't like me, right? That's called the self-promotion product. So it's very hard to get to both because there is that trade-off. The warmer we are, there's a chance that we may look less competent. And the more competent and smart and high status and respectable we look, we may look more distant and less likable and less warm. Some strategies work. One is definitely humor when it's done well. So if he can incorporate humor in a smart way, it's one of these rare strategies that signal both how smart you are, but also it makes us very likable. Another thing that I referred to in my previous answer, was when we talk about our journeys, we still convey a lot of competence and we don't lose the warmth. People still like us more and find us relatable. What do I mean by that when I say journey?
他们拥有博士学位。他们是一个非常有趣的人，在职业生涯中取得了所有这些成就。反之亦然，你知道，如果我表现得很有能力，如果我传达了我的专业知识，如果我只是谈论我的成就，那么人们就不会喜欢我，对吧？这就是所谓的“自我推销悖论”。所以两者兼顾非常困难，因为存在这种权衡。我们表现得越亲切，就越有可能显得能力不足。而我们表现得越能干、越聪明、地位越高、越受人尊敬，我们可能看起来就越疏远、越不讨人喜欢、越不亲切。有些策略是有效的。幽默绝对是一种，只要运用得当。如果能巧妙地融入幽默，这是一种罕见的策略，既能体现你的聪明才智，又能让我们非常讨人喜欢。我在上一个回答中提到的另一件事是，当我们谈论自己的历程时，我们依然能传达出很多能力，而且不会失去亲和力。人们依然更喜欢我们，并觉得我们平易近人。当我提到“历程”时，我是什么意思？
Like we even have a definition of the journey too, and I remember I took some notes. So we defined it as a long and often difficult process of going from one point to another. And basically when you share your journey, and we all had journeys, right? We all had long and difficult path for something. And basically, it reflects our determination to learn how we learn the new skill and how we grow as a person. And I'm going to give you an example by that. And the tricky thing here, when we are in a job interview, when we are in a work happy hour, when we are in a reception where we try to network with people, because we have limited time,
就像我们对“历程”也有定义，我记得我做了一些笔记。我们将其定义为从一点到另一点的漫长且通常困难的过程。基本上，当你分享你的历程时——我们都有过历程，对吧？我们都经历过漫长而艰难的道路。基本上，它反映了我们学习新技能的决心以及我们作为个人的成长。我将为此举个例子。这里棘手的地方在于，当我们参加求职面试、参加工作后的欢乐时光、或者参加试图与人建立联系的招待会时，因为我们的时间有限，
we usually just list our accomplishments. So I did this, I did that. And it seems like a journey too, but it's not really because. we only list our outcomes, our accomplishments. But instead of saying, for instance, oh, I graduated from this school, if I tell people, oh, I actually learned English, started learning English at the age of 15, and I came to US as a college student, now there's a whole different story there, right? There is a whole, and I'm sure all of us have lots of different things like that.
我们通常只是列出我们的成就。所以我做了这个，我做了那个。这看起来也像是一个历程，但实际上并非如此，因为我们只列出了结果和成就。但如果我不说“我从这所学校毕业”，而是告诉人们“我其实是在15岁时开始学习英语的，后来作为大学生来到美国”，那这里就有一个完全不同的故事了，对吧？这里有一个完整的故事，我相信我们所有人都有很多类似的事情。
So if we share, instead of just focusing on the outcome or accomplishment, if you can say just a couple more sentences, oh, you know, I had to work. extra hours to get this position, you know, or I learned this language or I learned this new skill or I navigated all of that when I had my kid. Like all of these things give much more personal information and journey and how you made sense of your growth and development. And that's way more interesting for the other party to listen to. So sharing journey information is another strategy that help us being both likable and
所以，如果我们分享时不仅仅关注结果或成就，如果你能多说几句，比如“你知道，我为了得到这个职位不得不加班加点”，或者“我学习了这门语言，或者我学习了这项新技能，或者我在有了孩子后克服了所有这些困难”。所有这些事情提供了更多个人信息和历程，以及你是如何理解自己的成长和发展的。这对对方来说要有趣得多。因此，分享历程信息是另一种帮助我们既讨人喜欢又
respectable and get high ratings on both warmth and competence. Oh, gratitude is a very good one. I think, although, I mean, with LinkedIn post gratitude, sometimes people also question the sincerity of gratitude posts as well, which is some research we are doing right now. But if gratitude has clear targets, like if you, like instead of just saying, I'm grateful, I got this job, If you say, I'm so grateful to my teammates, my mentor, like if there are actual people that you're grateful to. People love gratitude, even if you brag. So that's another strategy that makes the bragging a little warmer. In general, I would recommend sharing brag attempts or accomplishments with positive emotion is very effective.
受人尊敬，并在亲和力和能力方面获得高评价的策略。哦，感恩是一个非常好的策略。虽然，我的意思是，在LinkedIn上发布感恩内容时，人们有时也会质疑感恩帖的真诚度，这也是我们目前正在研究的内容。但如果感恩有明确的对象，比如，与其只说“我很感激我得到了这份工作”，如果你说“我非常感谢我的队友、我的导师”，如果确实有你感激的具体人。人们喜欢感恩，即使你在炫耀。所以这是另一种让炫耀变得稍微亲切一点的策略。总的来说，我建议带着积极的情绪分享炫耀的尝试或成就是非常有效的。
Like, people love it when we say, I'm really so excited. No, I'm genuinely over the moon for this. for this graduation, something like that. And one key thing I want to say, this is more about emotion research, not necessarily impression management research, but as an impression management researcher, I'm very interested in the study of pride,
比如，人们喜欢我们说“我真的太兴奋了。不，我真的为这次毕业感到无比高兴”，诸如此类。我想说的一个关键点是，这更多是关于情绪研究，不一定是印象管理研究，但作为一名印象管理研究员，我对自豪感的研究非常感兴趣，
as I mentioned, it's a very interesting, self-conscious emotion. So there are, the researchers, pride researchers distinguish two distinct types of pride. One is hubristic pride. The other is authentic pride. So hubristic pride is all about, I'm superior, I'm great,
正如我提到的，这是一种非常有趣的自我意识情绪。研究人员将自豪感区分为两种截然不同的类型。一种是傲慢的自豪，另一种是真实的自豪。所以傲慢的自豪感完全是关于“我优越，我很棒”，
like, I'm just so great. You just get that vibe from hebristic pride, whereas authentic pride is really all about, you know, I work so hard and finally I get this. And people really respond to that in a very positive way. So anytime we feel that emotion, pride, that sweet pride, if we sort of check ourselves and say, you know, I'm really being authentic about this, do I really share all the background, all the hard work, all the, you know, sleepless nights or extra hard work or extra hardship that I had to overcome to. achieve this, then people respond to it in a more positive way and you don't necessarily have the trade-off between warmth and competence. So these are just some of the strategies there. Are the rules different on social media? Because, I mean, half of what I see on there is people saying, oh, I'm in Budapest today and tomorrow I'm going to be in Croatia. Or here's this beautiful
就像“我就是这么棒”。你从傲慢的自豪感中只会得到那种感觉，而真实的自豪感确实是关于“你知道，我工作非常努力，终于得到了这个”。人们对此的反应非常积极。所以每当我们感受到那种情绪——自豪，那种甜蜜的自豪时，如果我们审视一下自己，说“你知道，我对此真的很真诚，我是否真的分享了所有的背景、所有的努力、所有的（你知道）不眠之夜或我为了实现这一目标而必须克服的额外艰辛”，那么人们会以更积极的方式回应，你就不必在亲和力和能力之间进行权衡。这些只是一些策略。社交媒体上的规则不同吗？因为，我的意思是，我在上面看到的一半内容是人们说“哦，我今天在布达佩斯，明天我要去克罗地亚”。或者“这是我们昨晚吃的美味
meal that we had last night and you had to eat home and you probably ate leftovers. You know, I mean, that's the sense that I get from reading a lot of the things that people I know post. And these are my friends. It's not that I dislike them because they're showing me that they're doing something fabulous, but are the rules different for social media and are people's reactions different? I mean, that's a great question because we all know social media is bragging Olympics. And it's very interesting, all of them became that way. You know, at first, maybe Instagram seemed like a very, everyone is having this amazing life filled with amazing meals, amazing trips, amazing hobbies.
餐点”，而你却不得不待在家里，可能吃着剩菜。你知道，我的意思是，这就是我从阅读我认识的人发布的大量内容中得到的感觉。而且这些人是我的朋友。并不是因为他们向我展示他们在做一些美妙的事情我就不喜欢他们，但社交媒体的规则是否不同？人们的反应是否不同？我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题，因为我们都知道社交媒体是炫耀奥林匹克。而且非常有趣，所有平台都变成了那样。你知道，起初，Instagram似乎是一个每个人都过着充满美妙餐点、美妙旅行、美妙爱好的精彩生活的地方。
Sometimes, you know, when I see people's hobbies, again, I'm very happy for them, but I always think, how did they find the time? You know, I barely, you know, survive with just like a few things I need to do given, you know, day. And LinkedIn has become that too. And LinkedIn also became, people share lots of things with their photos and about their personal lives, too. I don't know about your LinkedIn, but I started to say. see a lot of sort of personal milestones. Maybe people don't put like Paris trip to their LinkedIn, but they still do share a lot of personal life updates in a good way. I think social media has changed the game in a bit that it made it very visible and pervasive. So it changed the norms. I
有时，你知道，当我看到人们的爱好时，我再次为他们感到高兴，但我总是想，他们是怎么找到时间的？你知道，考虑到一天的时间，我几乎只能勉强应付我需要做的几件事。LinkedIn也变成了那样。LinkedIn也变成了人们分享很多带有照片和个人生活的内容的地方。我不知道你的LinkedIn怎么样，但我开始看到很多所谓的个人里程碑。也许人们不会把巴黎之旅发到LinkedIn上，但他们确实以一种好的方式分享了很多个人生活动态。我认为社交媒体在某种程度上改变了游戏规则，因为它使炫耀变得非常明显和普遍。所以它改变了规范。我
think we think it's more okay to brag now. So probably that's why when I find my first tweet saying I like to cut seems like, seems very naive and kind of misdeme. the point to me. The other thing is, of course, in general, the rules, same rules apply. Like, gratitude is great if it's done in a smart way and real way rather than, if you just say I'm so humbled to be here, people don't think you're necessarily humble, right? Like, people are actually a little aversive to some words, but in general, gratitude, positive emotions, and directness, like being a little more direct, like, you know, like hundreds of hours of work, and finally here I am, something like that would be way more effective than humble bragging, saying,
认为我们现在觉得炫耀更可以接受了。所以这可能就是为什么当我发现我第一条推文说我喜欢剪辑时，看起来非常天真，对我来说有点不合时宜。另一件事是，当然，总的来说，规则是一样的。比如，如果以聪明和真实的方式进行，感恩是非常棒的，而不是如果你只是说“我很荣幸能来到这里”，人们并不一定认为你很谦虚，对吧？人们实际上对某些词有点反感，但总的来说，感恩、积极的情绪和直接性，比如更直接一点，比如“你知道，数百小时的工作，终于我到了这里”，类似这样的话会比谦虚的炫耀有效得多，比如，
oh, I don't even know, I don't even know that my students selected me for, I can't believe, you know. I'm getting this teaching award again. So generally the rules are the same. In terms of people who never share things, who share only the accomplishments, I think that also backfires a little bit. I think the social media piece is very exciting for us researchers because now things are really changing, right? We see also the behavior differences between different generations. If you ever look at TikTok, you know, the norms there are even more different because it's a more video-based app. And the younger generations, the Gen Z members, make videos that are almost like, they even make fun of,
“哦，我甚至不知道，我甚至不知道我的学生选我为……我不敢相信，你知道，我再次获得了这个教学奖。”所以总的来说，规则是一样的。对于那些从不分享事情、只分享成就的人，我认为这也会适得其反。我认为社交媒体的部分对我们研究人员来说非常令人兴奋，因为现在情况真的在改变，对吧？我们也看到了不同世代之间的行为差异。如果你看过TikTok，你知道，那里的规范甚至更不同，因为它是一个更基于视频的应用程序。年轻一代，Z世代的成员，制作的视频几乎就像，他们甚至取笑，
I don't know if you heard of this, but they even make fun of the millennial pause, which is this idea that when you're you put the camera, I think older generations starting with millennials, we do this thing. Where the camera starts, we do have this slight pause where you just pause and look at the camera and you're ready. Whereas for the Gen Z members, you know, they start there, they start talking immediately when they put on makeup or like cook and it's like a normal thing. Yeah. Oh, oh, here's a day. There's a day at Harvard University as a freshman student. You know, what do I do here? Because for them, they are. are much more concerned about the feeling of cringe.
我不知道你是否听说过这个，但他们甚至取笑“千禧一代的停顿”，这是一个概念，即当你放置相机时，我认为从千禧一代开始的老一代人，我们会做这件事。相机开始时，我们确实有轻微的停顿，你只是停顿一下，看着相机，准备好了。而对于Z世代的成员，你知道，他们从那里开始，当他们化妆或做饭时，他们立即开始说话，这就像一件正常的事情。是的。“哦，哦，这是在哈佛大学作为大一新生的一天。你知道，我在这里做什么？”因为对他们来说，他们更关心尴尬的感觉。
So they don't even want to look like they're trying. So that's the term that we're learning from social media as well. So generally, some rules are the same, meaning that you've got to be direct. You've got to be, you've got to show gratitude and hopefully talk about your authentic pride and journey, how you got there, your hard work and how you grow as a sense of person. So general rules of bragging work. but there are different norms because there are different generations coming along and they change the norms and they you know you don't want to seem like you're trying too hard that's why even the number of words you put on your status on social media some people argue that that may reveal your age you know if you write this long paragraph you are like an older millennial whereas if you sort of if you sort of say just one sentence as if you're not trying that's much more of a younger younger generation person's attempt to attempt to soft promote so I find it fascinating that
所以他们甚至不想看起来像是在努力。所以这是我们从社交媒体上学到的术语。所以总的来说，有些规则是一样的，意味着你必须直接。你必须，你必须表现出感恩，并希望谈论你真实的自豪感和历程，你是如何到达那里的，你的努力工作以及你如何作为一个人成长。所以炫耀的一般规则是有效的，但有不同的规范，因为有不同的世代出现，他们改变了规范，而且你，你知道，你不想看起来像是在过度努力。这就是为什么即使你在社交媒体上发布状态的字数，有些人认为这可能会暴露你的年龄。你知道，如果你写这长长的一段话，你就像一个年长的千禧一代，而如果你，如果你只说一句话，好像你没有在努力，那更像是年轻一代人的软推销尝试。所以我发现这很迷人，
But some roles are the same, but some roles are definitely changing there. So I have to ask, because you mentioned it, and of course it's elsewhere in your bio, in addition to your work as a researcher and a professor, you do stand-up comedy. Does your research on impression management help you in your comedy? I mean, do you work it into your routine? Yeah, absolutely. It's impossible not too well. First of all, in general, because I'm, you know, I studied organizational behavior in grad
但有些规则是一样的，但有些规则在那里绝对在改变。所以我必须问，因为你提到了它，当然它也在你的简历的其他地方，除了作为研究员和教授的工作外，你还做单口喜剧。你关于印象管理的研究对你的喜剧有帮助吗？我的意思是，你把它融入到你的表演中了吗？是的，绝对。不可能不融入。首先，总的来说，因为我，你知道，我在研究生院学习组织行为学，
at school, so I'm very interested in behavioral science and what mistakes people make and how can we fix that. And in my research, I focus specifically on impression management mistakes. You know, comedy is also all about mistakes. If you go on stage and talk about how great things are, it's not funny. You know, it has to be, you know, Mark Twain has this famous quote, there's no, there's no humor in heaven because everything is so great there. So in a way, you know, comedy is impression management in real time, because you've got to talk about these mistakes, but also to be funny, you've got to manage the impressions too, because there is a timing, you've got to be vulnerable, and soft-dification usually works as a comedian, and soft-depication is an interesting
所以我对行为科学非常感兴趣，人们会犯什么错误以及我们如何解决这些错误。在我的研究中，我专门关注印象管理错误。你知道，喜剧也完全是关于错误的。如果你上台谈论事情有多棒，那并不好笑。你知道，它必须是，你知道，马克·吐温有一句名言，“天堂里没有幽默，因为那里的一切都太棒了”。所以从某种意义上说，你知道，喜剧是实时的印象管理，因为你必须谈论这些错误，但为了好笑，你也必须管理印象，因为有节奏，你必须脆弱，而自嘲作为喜剧演员通常很有效，自嘲也是一种有趣的
impression management strategy as well, where you can cultivate a lot of warmth and likeability points. My research makes me very meta-aware of these dynamics, you know. So I always experiment with impression management on stage, I should say. And these are two favorite topics of mine. I love talking about impression management and studying it, and I love comedy, and I love thinking about what makes something funny and relatable. And, you know, sometimes I run experiments. Sometimes I make a joke.
印象管理策略，你可以培养很多亲和力和讨人喜欢的点。我的研究使我对这些动态有很强的元认知。所以，我应该说，我总是在舞台上试验印象管理。这些是我最喜欢的两个话题。我喜欢谈论印象管理并研究它，我喜欢喜剧，我喜欢思考是什么让事情变得有趣和引起共鸣。而且，你知道，有时我进行实验。有时我讲个笑话。
And if people laugh, I know it's real. And if my data works, I know it's real. Well, Dr. Sezer, I want to thank you for joining me today. You've made a great impression. Oh, thank you so much. You too. Thanks, we are a great team. Such a pleasure to join.
如果人们笑了，我就知道它是真实的。如果我的数据有效，我就知道它是真实的。好的，Sezer博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。你给我留下了深刻的印象。哦，非常感谢。你也是。谢谢，我们是一个很棒的团队。很高兴能参加。
Thanks a lot. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinemann. Thank you for listening.
非常感谢。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下评论。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinemann 制作。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。